hi my name is Jack and I work on the
calendar application for Android I'd
like to tell you about two features
today that I really like about the
calendar application one is that you can
have public calendars on your phone so
for example if you forget when Easter is
you can have the Christian holidays on
the phone you can also have all the US
holidays and there are many other public
calendars that you can load another
thing I like is the auto link feature
for example if you have a web URL
embedded in anywhere in the text of the
event that URL is automatically linked
so that if you select it it will take
you to the browser and bring up that web
page likewise if you have a phone number
and you select that phone number it will
take you to the dialer where you can
make the call